newly arrived somalis who have fled
drought are being vetted before being
registered as refugees in Kenya some of
those who've managed to get here have
also escaped ongoing fighting government
forces and Regional troops are
continuing their offensive against the
armed group al-shabab Aidan Muhammad
nurse says the slow verification process
is one last obstacle he did not need
I've been here since early morning the
vetting has just started but there is no
order there is no proper order
security has been heightened in and
around the Dada refugee camp three
border policemen were recently killed
after their vehicle run over and
improvised explosive device on a busy
road security officials blame al-shabab
Fighters for using the comps to carry
out attacks everyone here is on edge our
border is very porous though we have the
security patrol we have our units that
are there for patrolling our borders I
can say that those who sneak they cannot
come to the camp and just enter into the
camps without being known
more than 100 000 somalis have crossed
into Kenya since last year this is in
addition to refugees who have been in
the camps some of them since 1991 when
they fled Civil War some other refugees
come to camps like this one where they
have relatives but here's the problem
some government officials say this could
compromise National Security
Osman has just arrived she says her
Village in lower Juba is under the
control of al-shabab
we came here because of drought but I
also had security concerns armed men
will take my property I was afraid of my
daughters it's easy for them to be
forcefully married off I cannot protect
them
back at the refugee verification Center
some manage to get through they now have
a food token and a government alien card
they say they don't want trouble they
just want to be safe Catherine soy Al
Jazeera dadab refugee camp in
northeastern Kenya